what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel before i start do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos by the way you guys already know
if you have watched two or more of my
videos and you do not subscribe we have
beef people
beef
okay so today
i think the manosphere may be wrong this
video came up on my like
suggested page
and this man was making a lot of points
that disagree without a lot of the like
founders of the man of sphere like rolo
tomasi and
um even like donovan fresh and fit all
those guys so
i change opinions with new information
so
i want you guys to watch me
and see if i change my opinion on this
let's go
my recent academic work
i emphasize academic work on gender
sexuality
men and women
had provoked a tsunami of responses from
red pillars
black pillars
and other pillars of the manosphere
community
that ejected and rejected men in the
insulin communities
and the angry
men in mgtow men going their own way
they congratulate me on my recent
conversion and welcome me to the fold
there's only one problem with that
i think absolutely everything these
people say
is
rank nonsense
sheer
unmitigated inanity based on
nothing whatsoever
and i'm going to dedicate this short
video because i don't think they deserve
more i'm going to dedicate this short
video
to refuting
some of their claims and debunking some
of the myths
around which their puny minds revolve
the people there strike me and i've
spent i've spent a considerable amount
have wasted a considerable amount of
time in their forums the men there
strike me as psychopathic and
narcissistic in the vast majority of
cases
or depressive they call this red pill
rage sir
it's red pill rage
anxious and exceedingly rageful
and so this is not a good mix it's a
toxic mix it's toxic masculinity at its
worst
and that is not to say the toxic
masculinity is limited to men it's my
view that it has infected women and that
they are now emulating actually these
very men that they are castigating as
feminists
okay let's get to the point my name is
sam vaknin i'm the author of malignant
self-love narcissism revisited and in my
other hat i'm a professor of psychology
so everything i say to you now i also
teach in the various universities i
lecture in
let's start with a few basic basic facts
um
many wannabe geniuses and cult leaders
who shall remain unnamed
propound the idea that the pareto
principle
the pareto
principle applies to dating and to
mating
put simply
20
of men
are going to garner
80
of women women women's favors are going
to be bestowed on twenty percent of men
and eighty percent of men shall remain
unlaid in other words eighty percent of
men find it difficult if not impossible
to get laid okay
i don't think that's what the
red pill teaches that's what i thought
they taught when i first started
listening to it
but what the pareto principle is is 80
of women when they list out like what
their ideal partner looks like it's 20
of men now when i was on the fresh and
fit podcast
i did
think that the 2080 rule was like over
simplified like i felt like
more guys were getting laid than they
were saying
so i'm gonna just let them keep talking
and then i'll finish that point
twenty percent of men
uh bed or have sex with eighty percent
of all the women
there are several problems with this
with this idea
one it's not true
and but that's a minor issue the major
issue is the pareto principle cannot be
applied
to this kind of analysis of population
and behaviors
anyone who applies the pareto principle
to dating
has no idea about mathematics and i
strongly suspect has no idea about
dating
here are the facts established in
numerous multiple studies in dozens of
countries with tens of thousands of
women in all age groups
women prefer
what the monosphere call
better males
they prefer
men who are not what the manosphere
calls alpha males what the monosphere
calls alpha males by the way
is not the same thing
as the scientific alpha male
in science we have the concept of alpha
male especially among primates
and the alpha male among primates is
compassionate a compassionate coalition
builder
the
what makes the alpha male an alpha male
among for example gorillas or
chimpanzees
is his ability to empathize and then to
construct social coalitions
the alpha male of the monosphere
is simply a brute a thug
a muscle-bound idiot
a narcissist and very often a psychopath
that's the kind of perception these
these men have about what it is to be
alpha
so women find this kind of men obnoxious
and women prefer
what the monosphere calls better males
even for one night stands
definitely for long i said this
i said this i was like i think i like
beta males
like i think i because i i always said i
always like the laid-back guys or the
funny guys those are my two types
i was like do i like beta males
and
everyone was saying like oh
the women will like
the alpha males and when i
oh my god i thought this too
i thought this too sort of okay i'm
gonna keep going relationships but even
for one-night stands
there are numerous studies supporting
this
when women select someone for a
one-night stand
they put emphasis
on
his looks that part is true but not his
good looks
his looks
whether his looks trigger them whether
his looks appeals to them whether they
find his looks compatible with their
preferences it doesn't have to be good
looking it just has to look the right
way for that specific woman
and that is so true women have such
different preferences
yeah that's true that's true although i
think tall is like something that women
like across the board i will say that
more importantly
his his ability to express affection and
compassion to empathize to converse
intelligently
these are much more critical in the eyes
of women
than any good looks and that is true
also for casual sex
this is why friends with benefits
is the dominant model for casual sex
and not hookups actually
contra contrary to the rabid imagination
of the members of the men in the
manuscript
hookups are very few and far between
hookups are rare okay
this is what i said
this is what i said when
i was talking to donovan i was saying i
don't know girls that do this crazy
stuff all the time
like i know
you know girls that
turn on my other light
i know girls that like
maybe like from time to time
occasionally but like the way they would
make it sound is like oh these girls get
flown out every weekend and are hooking
up with a new guy every month i'm like
that is not what i've seen but
friends with benefits are much more
common
yeah friends with benefits that's very
true yeah that's very common but
nowadays it's like there's almost like a
talking stage before you date everything
as i've said i'm not a fan of modern
dating culture everything moves so much
faster
nonsense number two hypergamy
women marry up or at least sick to marry
her they want to marry up they want to
marry men
who are richer
wealthier they want to marry men who are
higher than they are
in terms of social status access power
money etc etc that is unfortunately
also another bit of nonsense
in the last 40 years
women had been marrying down
not up
first of all the marriage rate had
declined by 50 percent
between 1990 and today
and in committed relationships and in
what remains of marriage women are
marrying down
now women are marrying down not because
they want to marry down
but because they have no choice
women have been well i think that is
similar to what the man owes fear says
they say like women
marry down if they i think that that's
similar to what the man knows
more educated than men
and women earn as much as men when we
adjust the earnings
so women have as much money as men
they are more educated than men way more
educated by the way
and they are
as masculine as men they are adventurous
they're sexual they had become men in
effect
and so
because they had become men
they now select men the same way men
used to select women
men used to marry them
statistically now women are marrying
down because women are the new men that
is not some vaccine these are multiple
studies
by lisa wade
and
and many others
the next bit of nonsense
women screw around
women are all over the place especially
younger women women under the age of 35.
they
they are on the seacower cell they they
accumulate a body count they they are
unconscionable about it they they get
drunk and they sleep around with dozens
of men well is that here's the fact here
are the facts
young women have much less sex with much
with much fewer partners
than their mothers
and
shock of all shocks their grandmothers
i repeat this sentence
that's interesting that i was not
expecting i i need to know i tried to
look in the description to see if i
could like look at the studies and i
didn't see them but this guy does seem
to know what he's talking about
younger women
have much less sex
with many fewer partners
than their mothers
and grandmothers
hookups are common
mainly and only in college settings
and mainly and only among white folk
white women and men
wait for real
damn
even there
hookups are much more in the imagination
of the participants than in reality on
average there's one hookup per semester
about one third of college
graduates
end up being virgins
and
the average
is two to three hookups for the entire
duration
in four years
so hookups are a myth
friends with benefits is much more
common there's much more common
arrangement which of course precludes
immediately the idea of pareto
and
women
now
trade down they marry down
next
next nonsense
women con women do not consume as much
pornography as men
wrong again women wait what
i have never seen porn minus i told you
guys the story about that one time in
college when i told this guy in my lobby
like i wasn't dating him or talking to
him or anything he was just we were just
like friends and i was like yeah i've
never seen porn before because like
people were it made sense in the
conversation and then he was like
let me show you and i was like oh no
that's okay you really don't have to and
he's like oh no no i need to show you i
need to be a part of this and i'm like
oh no no no
anyways
i get peer pressured easily so i was
like okay fine um
i felt very awkward it's not my thing um
ew so besides that which i don't do you
really count that i guess it counts but
um
i've never seen porn so this is
surprising to me women consume more
pornography than men but of a different
kind first of all one third
of pornography consumption goes to women
women consume one-third of all
pornography consumed
so that's not a small number
but if you add to that
sexually explicit romantic literature
yes you know the old kind
fifty shades of grey words and texts and
books i haven't read that
i also don't read but
or watch movies i just watch youtube
video i guess i'm weird
i wouldn't doubt it though i know a lot
of people that read 50 shades of grey
if you add that to the mix
if you add to the mix online text like
literatica and other websites
then women actually consume
more pornography than men but not of the
visual kind they consume mostly
text-based pornography and the reason is
very simple
men are triggered sexually
by visuals
men are able to climax there it's like
women fall in love with what they hear
men fall in love with what they see
orgasm when they're exposed to a picture
of a body part or a video of a body part
women are unable to do that and that's
why dick pics don't work with women
they don't
man keep your dick pics we don't want
them keep them off the
monosphere oh
okay just
sorry someone was texting me for a
second so i got a little distracted but
i just want to put in some thoughts
i really didn't think that many men were
sexless
maybe like the bottom because i think
rollo has a stat that said like the
bottom thirty percent but when i was on
fresh fit they made it seem like it was
like five to twenty percent of guys are
smashing everyone i'm like is that low
and i
oh wait i don't think he's talked about
the next part that i was about to say he
will hold on okay
let's proceed in dismantling the
nonsensical edifice of the monosphere
geniuses they have a lot of brawn but
very little brain it seems
studies in the past 40 years have
upended
everything we thought we knew about
female sexuality in the west
here are a few nuggets for your
edification
women orgasm mostly
from digital or oral clitoral
stimulation
penetration
doesn't do it for them
anal sex
is painful
choking is medically dangerous and
terrifying and yet
in hookups
most men
attempt to have anal intercourse
and
many men choke their partners without
any free advice ah i know some girls
that are into the choking thing
warning or consultation
so
very few men
give their sexual partners in hookups
and in first dates
oral sex
and this is one of the main reasons
women are avoiding casual sex in
increasing numbers casual sex is
massively on the decline
sales of condoms for example have been
going down four to five percent a year
so
next
truth
women are likelier to cheat
you ask anyone in the manuscript and
they will tell you the reason we are not
getting married is because the
government and social institutions
favor women
and they leverage these institutions to
abscond with our our hard earned
uh earnings and livelihood
children and what have you well i think
a lot of them would say it's because
there's like a 50 divorce rate and the
courts do favor women second argument is
it's not a good idea to have a committed
relationship with a woman because she's
gonna cheat
well that's quite true
uh cheating had quadrupled among women
but it is still
it still has
to reach the level of cheating among men
and
women are likelier to cheat
during estrus
the sun is in my eyes so i'm gonna
switch and change
the angle
women are much likelier to cheat when
they're ovulating during estrus the rest
of the the rest of the month
they're much less likely to cheat than
men
watch your girl
watch your girl when she's ovulating
what about homicide
i always have felt like
a lot of the measures taken in the
mannosphere are a little extreme i'm not
trying to be like a grifter okay i'm not
i agree with a lot of stuff the
manosphere says i really do
but but i'm always gonna have a butt
there are certain things that have
always just been kind of like odd to me
like
i'm gonna speak carefully like girls
nights out okay
i understand no no grown-ass woman
should be in the club
but if her and her friends want to go
like hang out at a at a bar or at like a
a place where men will be and and not
like talk to them what's the big deal i
never understood the big deal in that or
um say
like i've heard men say like they can
never have a girl have a male personal
trainer i'm like
i guess
i don't know just a lot of this stuff
seemed kind of extreme
where because i watched my parents be
married forever and neither of them
cheated and neither of them were like
controlling of each other like they both
kind of just let each other do what they
wanted and they both just chose to not
do crazy stuff you know i don't know but
sexuality lesbianism and so
women prefer women
yes
men of the manuscript women don't want
you not even sexually women prefer women
women are three times more likely to be
lesbian than men are to be homosexual
women find in other women
the kind of sensitivity physiological
physical sensitivity and emotional
sensitivity that they can't find with
men
women are more attuned to each other's
pleasure and women provide much better
companions even in casual sex
so
women increasingly are preferring women
as sex partners and as one of them told
me it may be an acquired habit
it is true
all in all
that women prefer good-looking men for
one-night stands
and men with stable income for long-term
relationships
consequently
sexlessness in couples
is at an all-time high around 21
officially i believe at least double
and infidelity is off the charts 45
percent for women and 60 for men 45
for women and
60 for men oh my gosh
oh that's so high
the numbers are likely
massively under reported
but
there are no studies
i repeat there are no serious studies
that support the belief
that women choose
sex partners or long-time bodies i'm
gonna try to get this man on my podcast
i need to get him on my channel
based on looks
no sir if you're watching this please
come on my channel please studies
support this
in on dating apps
matches
usually gravitate towards good looking
men in other words women would tend to
respond much more
to good looking men
but here's the catch
they will not meet these good looking
men
they will not go to bed with these good
looking men in other words it's all talk
and no walk
actually i
this i was going to say earlier because
i watched this part of the video i said
on fresh and fit that dating apps did
not reflect real life and nobody
gave me the time of day even the girls
didn't believe me i'm like they're like
well dating apps is where we can be
honest but here's the thing here's the
thing with dating apps if i meet you off
a dating nap i don't know you the only
information i have is meeting you in
person like from the internet like i
don't know who your friends are i don't
know who your family is i don't know
what you do for a living you could lie
to me completely and i i
i don't know
i don't know who you are okay
and
with that information right
like
and then you get you get so many so much
attention on a dating app so if i get a
dating app i could probably have like a
thousand matches in a day how okay so
how do i filter through a thousand
matches of course i'm gonna pick like
the best ones
if i have a thousand dollar like let's
save a hundred right
why wouldn't i pick the top 10 to 20
like that better have the things i look
for right
that's my only option like you have so
much [ __ ] like flooding in
that it's like okay what am i gonna do
with all this okay
so then of course you pick like the top
guy but in real life in real life but
then if you let's say i go on a date
with him right i'm gonna continue that
thought let's say i go on a date with
him
i still don't know who is like the
report would take him so much longer to
build rapport with me than if i just met
someone around me or at my school or at
like through common friends or people my
family knows like stuff like that is
way
the way like i would prefer that so much
because you have so much more
information so if i met someone online
like it would take me
way longer to hypothetically hook up or
date with him
right because
like that's all the information i have
so i knew i
knew
that that did not reflect real life i
knew
i knew it
because
it just didn't make sense to me and it
with what i've seen too
and like we're not as picky in person i
mean we women are picky so don't don't
discount that we are picky but in person
like
on the app like for for me like the guys
that are interested in me
are way hotter than the guys that are
interested in me in real life i'm just
being honest
but it's not like
like i would still prefer the less
attractive guys that i meet in real life
because i know who they are i know
they're real i know who they're who they
say they are
i know they're not gonna probably kill
me
now i'm not
i'm not even dating anybody right now
but i'm just like giving you guys
examples so you understand what i'm
talking about
and
like same with the friends like the
friends with benefits thing like when
you're friends with someone you have so
much more information about them
anyway sorry i'm done with that tangent
a tiny tiny tiny tiny shall i say again
tiny fraction
of swipes
end up in face face-to-face real-life
meetings and an even tinier fraction of
these meetings
ends up in having sex
these are the facts
so yes
women fantasize about good looking men
on dating apps they chat with them
they match up with them
they even may consider having
a drink
but
in the overwhelming vast majority of
cases
this
dating up action
is not going to translate
into irl action in real life actually in
the vast majority of cases is anyone who
had ever used the dating app can confirm
what about the sexual fantasies of women
the two main sexual fantasies of women
are
to be kidnapped and raped
and to participate in an orgy or a
gangbang
but only eight percent of women act on
the latter fantasy in other words only
five to eight percent of women depending
on the country participate in group sex
of any kind three sons included so women
are not as emancipated empowered as
liberated as they liked themselves to as
they like to think of themselves social
stigma stills carry an important role in
weight
which leads me to the next point
women do desire casual sex
but not as much as men do
i repeat
it is a myth
it's a nonsensical myth
that women are more promiscuous than men
or women are as promiscuous as men they
are not
across cultures
across decades
across different societies
across different settings and
environments women of all ages
are much less likely
and this this also applies to women who
are lesbian
they're much less likely to want casual
sex than men in other words women are
more
socio-sexually restricted
than
than men
but as terry conley in her
groundbreaking studies had noted
perhaps the reason is
not sexual at all
women are afraid of risk
they're much more vulnerable than
exposed because they're much weaker and
smaller yeah so they're much more
terrified of risk they take risk into
account
yeah because you guys don't understand
the fear that just
i i know it's a statistically unlikely
that stuff happens to us
but
if we meet up with you like there's
always an underlining
fear
of [ __ ] going wrong
someone killing us i don't know
see that you see that look at my face
right there that was me being afraid
was at my door they're gonna break into
my apartment no one's there
but
i get nervous i get scared i don't know
much more than men do
they are subject to the double standard
and social stigma if they sleep around
and there is a minor issue of the orgasm
gap
only 10 of women orgasm in casual sex
compared to 75 percent of women in
long-term committed relationships
so
what happens if we remove these
obstacles
what happens if there's no risk
there's no social stigma and orgasm is
guaranteed
well
if you do that
if you remove these obstacles
women's willingness to engage in casual
sex
increases dramatically
they are even willing to bid totally
okay and this is what i talk about in my
channel take away the consequences
people tend to do the wrong thing
so right there he took away the
consequences people do the wrong thing
more or like hypothetically wrong like
the more risky thing whatever you know
depends on your world view right
strangers
given
that there's no risk
orgasm is guaranteed or some fantastic
sex
and the social stigma is not there
because for example the whole situation
is anonymous and in another another
country
so
we are not sure yet
whether
if
the situation for women and men
were utterly equitable
women would develop
unrestricted sociosexuality up to the
level of men
but right now
there's no equality no identity men want
sexual sex much more than women do and
men are willing to say yes
at the drop of a head actually men don't
care who is the woman i really would
like to see these studies i'm actually
very very interested but this guy seems
very knowledgeable and that's i think in
the red pill a lot of times
us as content creators so you have to
understand we don't have the time to do
like research and all that stuff takes a
lot of time i'm a reactor so i don't
even consider myself like a core like
red pill theory maker or i just
i'm logical i think that's why you guys
realize following me
so it's really just like i'll see an
idea and i'll like do my take on it but
i could be right i could be wrong i
don't know but
how do i put this the problem
is that i think a lot of content
creators like you have to you have to
manage so much stuff
that
you're not it's going to be tough to
beat a guy that his whole life has just
been spent
researching and studying this stuff like
he's gonna have a lot more information
that we don't have
so of course i'm gonna take his opinion
into account
but i'd like to see the studies and i'd
really like to see like
yeah i'd really like to see the studies
they've bid ugly women unattractive
women
they don't care if the woman is a
celebrity or an unknown and so while
women for example are much more willing
to have casual sex with celebrities
luckily for me
yeah that's true that's true
you you know they say a check mark okay
ignore the last comment
what about the circumstances of having
sex
most young women have sex
usually when they're drunk
there's been a coupling
of drinking and sex it starts in college
but even outside college settings
people today not only women actually
people today
men and women
especially if they're under the age of
35
they have sex only when they're drunk
so
being drunk and having sex
goes together
sober sex
is perceived to be
a signal of seriousness of commitment
of long term
so if you are having sex when you're
sober
you're saying to your partner i'm
interested in you in the long term
most casual sex
is drunk
and so
this creates a series of problems
which i will not go into right now but
this is a fact
women
do feel empowered and do feel desired
in casual sex
and even in group sex
actually what happens is
men usually initiate group sex
men coerce women
in many cases to participate in
threesomes majority of women report
that they did not want to participate in
a threesome but they wanted to please
their partner the men
so men initiated
but then having tried it
and having experienced it
men
want
want group sex less than women in other
words once women
had gone through the experience of group
sex once they've had for example the
first threesome
they want
much more of it and they want it much
more than men do
that's a that's a shocking twist i was
not expecting that and so women become
the drivers
of what
group sex activity in couples after the
first experience although they're very
reticent and reluctant before the first
experience
now here's a myth
here's a prevalent myth that women are
relationship oriented while men are sex
oriented
the truth is that both men and women
are interested in long-term
relationships although women are
marginally more interested it's about 10
more
like about two-thirds of men want a
long-term relationship and about
three-quarters of women want a long-term
relationship but
but
women tire
of
relationships much faster than men
we the the magic and charm of hmm
let's see i broke up with my last
boyfriend
i got dumped the one before that but i'm
about
50 50 committed long-term relationship
is lost on women
much faster than on men
men are much more invested and much more
committed and they want to perpetuate
the long-term relationship much more
than women because men benefit from
long-term relationships more than women
do
so
women tire of the sexual monotony how do
that's interesting i wonder how how that
is
men okay
of monogamy sooner than men many studies
show this
increasingly women are the ones who
avoid committed relationships altogether
about one third of women are lifelong
singles
the majority of divorces today but is
that because
their ass they waste their early years
and their smv goes down because that's
what it
it seems like
when i listen to a lot of the red pill
stuff
like men have more of the option to
remarry because women are more attracted
to traits rather than looks where it's
vice versa like men typically want like
younger women
um
and so like by the time a woman reaches
a certain age she can't get a man of a
certain caliber and if she can't get
that man of a certain caliber then she'd
rather just be by herself is that true
or not let me know in the comments i'm
not look guys i'm not an expert i would
say i know a lot of the red pill
philosophy very well
a lot of it makes sense to me
but
if this is better information it's
better information i just need to see
where he's getting this from are
initiated by women
a majority of female singles
turns celibate
but a substantial minority about 20
i did not have sex for two years before
i met my boyfriend lead the life of
hookups dating
and group sex in sex parties
wait what
oh gosh so
overall
women are withdrawing
men going their own way
women going their own way but women have
been doing it in much much longer larger
numbers than men
far fewer women are getting married
and they're having far fewer children
the replacement rate in all the
industrialized countries is unmet
populations all over
are aging and declining rapidly
everywhere from the uk to russia to
china
women place studies
career
travel and having fun with friends
way above
having a committed relationship
even as a majority of women
have this nebulous goal of getting
married one day
few women mention children in surveys
and studies few of them mention children
even as an aspirational goal
so children are off the table completely
in long-term relationships they become a
kind of
this
misty fantasy in the in the distant
future if at all
women are bitter many women are the
refugees
of abusive relationships and
so there's a
a giant population millions of people
alpha widow
tens of millions all over the world who
are who vowed or swore off any future
relationships and men they don't want to
have anything to do with men anymore
exactly as there are many men who don't
want to do anything with women anymore
the genders are going their own ways
both
about one third of women lifelong
singles and another another six
are lesbians so about half of all
uh woman womankind half of all women
folk are off the marketplace of the
sexual marketplace that's a much higher
percentage than among men
and the reason is that there is a
an asymmetry
in the benefits in long-term committed
relationships such as marriage
men benefit disproportionately more men
are healthier and make more money when
they are in marriages in a marriage for
example
and women make more money and are
marginally healthier
but they pay other kinds of prices their
freedoms are limited
they are psychologically um right but
isn't there research to show that if a
woman doesn't have a family like that
they are
the most lonely
group it's like women ate over the ages
of
let me know i don't know that's what i i
swear that's what the study was in much
much worse shape for example depression
and anxiety and so on so
there's a discrepancy here in a symmetry
and women are
hell-bent on dismantling what they
regard as patriarchal institutions
liberating and emancipating and
empowering themselves
and then doing nothing with it actually
as far as men are concerned because they
don't use this newfound freedom
emancipation and empowerment
to hook up to engage in casual sex
and to go wild what they do actually the
vast majority of them
they retreat into solitary lives with
netflix and a pet
several pets buy a dog and die alone and
they lead
single lives
until the day they die
spinster hood
is
is the new chic is the new
that's not good guys as a society that's
like that's not good
okay like that can't be the most
fulfilling version of life
although i guess that's what i'm doing
right now i live a lot but oh god
stay safe victorian times there were
spinsters
and the phenomenon had returned full
force
young people
are having less and less
dating had declined precipitously
hookups are down massively
young people
people under age 42
have simply withdrawn
fewer than 3 percent of men after age 32
are looking for a committed relationship
and the number is the same for women
under age 30.
this mismatch guarantees
that people are going to lead
solitary atomized life
lives whether they are men or women and
whatever their general equipment may be
we are all men now
some of us have penises some of us have
vaginas but that's an accident of nature
psychologically
socio-sexually
we are all men
it's a uni-gender world
and this is why the whole monosphere is
constructed on an entirely wrong
percept entirely wrong foundation this
is not a battle between genders between
men and women
it's a battle between two types of men
and this bodes ill
for the species
because men are aggressive
wade and others called this phenomenon
the stoned revolution
women had become men but men
did not
develop
um
their feminine side
they remained men
so now we have two types of men vowing
for supremacy
hating each other and i guess what's the
solution
i don't think the solution is that men
become more feminine right like i don't
see that being a good solution
i think as men
always did throughout human history and
where this is going to lead us
i dare not think
okay guys so the reason i wanted to show
you this is because i think it's
important that we get different points
of view
especially ones that seem a little bit
more credible to me
um
sorry i didn't talk as much as i would
have liked to just because
to be honest i really wanted you guys to
get the information
and i'm going to put a link to the full
video description
this guy
seems to really know what he's talking
about
but
who knows you know anyways don't forget
to subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell
i love you guys bye